the California parents accused of
holding their 13 children captive will
be in court today for procedural hearing
for the first time lawyers representing
the seven adult children are sharing how
their recovery is going and what their
dreams are for the future
Mireya Villarreal is outside the Paris
California home where the children were
allegedly held Mattea good morning good
morning those children were rescued here
at this home nearly six weeks ago
sources tell CBS News the six younger
siblings are actually living in two
foster homes right now and the seven
older siblings are actually staying at a
nearby Medical Center they are being
exposed to everything from Harry Potter
movies to using an iPad as the legal
case against David and Louise Turpin
moves forward the children they
allegedly imprisoned for years are
moving on with their lives making
decisions on their own for the first
time that in itself is kind of a a new
experience for them understanding that
they do have rights and they do have a
voice Jack Osbourne and Caleb Mason
represent the older siblings they say
the staff at the corona Medical Center
has converted part of the hospital to
make it more comfortable they set up an
outdoor area where they can play sports
and exercise prosecutors say the
siblings spent years in captivity
sometimes chained to their beds severely
underfed but now they're free to make
their own choices that's a big deal I'm
deciding what they're gonna read
deciding what they're gonna wear these
are all things that our decisions they
make every day which are new and and an
empowering Corona mayor Karen Spiegel
works closely with the siblings nurses
there talk about how warm and loving
these kids are and so appreciative some
of them had never really seen a
toothbrush before things that we just
take for granted means so much to these
kids the older and younger siblings have
not yet reunited but they communicate
using Skype in the short-term the
attorneys say the older children simply
want to go to the beach the mountains
and the movies but longer-term they want
to attend college and pursue careers I
just want you to
understand just what special individuals
they are they all have their own
aspirations and their own interests and
now they may have an opportunity to to
address those which is really exciting
the couple has pled not guilty to
multiple counts of child abuse torture
and false imprisonment if this does go
to trial the Riverside County District
Attorney says he does plan to put those
children on the witness stand
bianna hopefully these children who get
a second chance at a normal life Maria
thank you